[Musique]
boucher comme ça va tu es très élégant
merci vous devez lire et monsieur de sur
sac alors bertrand mecheri bertrand il
fera pas de chronique ce soir non voilà
qu'à me ferais chronique tout à l'heure
vous inquiétez pas il ya des beaux
gosses qui vont arriver
il y avait beaucoup de choses qui vont
se passer dans cette émission parce que
j'aurai des surprises pour vous tout ici
autour de la table on fera d'ailleurs
aussi un gros débat quel est votre beau
gosse de la télé je sais que ça va ça va
être chaud mais notre bertrand qu'on
aime fort il est il est venu me voir je
ne vous regarde pas il n'ya pas y'a pas
bas il ya juste un an juste avant
l'émission parce que on est en toute
transparence dans l'émission quand on a
un truc asie on se le dit en phase donc
je suis venu vous voir parce que je
parle aussi avec les gens de l'équipe de
la rédaction
moi j'ai toujours voulu faire ce métier
depuis que j'ai 4 ans parce que je
marche c'était ma passion
j aimerais tu me suis beaucoup amusé
pendant 2 ou un très fort mais apporte
beaucoup de choses je me suis éclaté
pendant de nombreuses années dans cette
émission est aujourd'hui je ressemble
moins de plaisir quand je fais les
chroniques je me sens moins à l'aise et
comme je suis c'est parce que vous aviez
en fait tu m'avais dit au fait qu' aussi
que vous êtes un peu gêné par tous qui
oui ah oui non mais j'allais venir je
vois là je ce qui va avec l'émission
l'émission cartonne donc il ya forcément
il ya beaucoup d'articles dès que
quelqu'un vous préfériez que vous aimez
mieux comme personnes nous regardent et
non c'est pas ça me suis ravi que
l'émission cartonne et c'est très bien
pour toutes les personnes qui la font
mais moi j'ai du mal pour mon cas
personnel
quand on dit un mot de travers qui est
12 articles derrière il y en a qui
vivent très bien la sur médiatisation
qui est due au succès d'émissions ça
n'est pas mon cas et aujourd'hui je
ressens le besoin de prendre du recul
par rapport à tout ça 2
aymar de tous les articles qui sortent
voilà sur touche pas à mon poste c'est
ce que m'avait dit de voir votre nom
sans foi voilà dès que vous tapez dans
google et ça vous ça vous au presse
bertrand il a 27 ans faut le savoir
et c'est vrai que voilà il est tout
jeune mon petit chou et c'est vrai que
des articles comme on a pu en voir sa
salsa salsa le ca le pen et c'est vrai
qu'il était était assez peiné et aussi
ça le jeu je crois voilà je pense que il
a envie de prendre un petit peu de recul
c'est ça fait ça j'ai besoin de prendre
du recul sur tout ça de me recentrer sur
moi ça veut pas dire que je n'aime pas
ce qu'est l'émission que je ne vous aime
pas vous que ce que je vous adore on a
tout reconnu bernard de 3 que j'ai avec
qui j'ai du mal mais ils le savent déjà
donc voilà je vous allez prendre un
petit peu de repos je vais prendre un
peu de recul de repos sur toile âge il
va il vous a dit allez y voir vous par
an exactement je sais qu'ils sont dans
la région paca voilà exactement et vous
reviendrez peut-être dans l'émission
mais ba bertrand est venu me voir et
j'ai et je dis faut jouer la
transparence on s'en est parlé tous les
deux sont nés par l'état dit jusque là
oui je le sens pas je me sens pas de
faire l'émission ce soir parce qu'il a
été voilà il a été affecté je peux
comprendre bertron et aussi parce que
comme voilà on joue pas de rôle dans
l'émission moi je ne peux pas jouer le
jeu le gars qui est bien dans les
messieurs ne me sens pas à l'aise de
venir sourit alors que j'ai pas envie de
sourire en ce moment et voila voila il
est il et voilà il a été touché par
parler les articles qui sont parus par
voilà les différentes choses qui ont été
dites sur les missions et notre bébert
c'est le plus jeune de l'équipe et c'est
normal que voilà peut-être il est il est
besoin de prendre un petit peu de recul
voilà vous restez avec nous deux petites
secondes le double si je vois qu'il est
voilà j'ai déjà de l'argent faire entrer
voilà je sais que va avoir un salaire à
payer en moins mais quand même
non mon bertrand voilà il reste avec
nous notre bertrand
qu'est ce qui se passe est minime vous
lui direz vous lui dirai tout haut d'un
instant voilà mais mon bébert tout va
bien avec mon bébé et vous dira il va
bien il a besoin de souffler tout seul
eichhoffen sofade d'accord on se
retrouve dans l'intention dé vie de
bertrand reste avec nous et on aura je
vous le dis dès grosse surprise pour
vous on aura vu frédéric bouraly et
gérard an dans des scènes de ménage et
on aura bien sûr franck gastambide
tiendra nous voir mais ils viennent tous
en beau gosse je vous le dis c'est que
du beau gars cia camille combal carré